نحن نتحقق الآن مما يمكن أن
يصبح فندقًا من فئة الخمس نجوم في المستقبل
نقول إنه يمكن أن يصبح لأنه
لم يتم بناؤه حتى الآن
سيتم استخدام بعض ميزاته
المقترحة لأول
مرة وهناك دراسات جارية للعثور على
إذا كان من المنطقي بناء هذا مع
التكلفة النهائية
غير المعروفة ، فمن الممكن أيضًا أن يفقد
القوة ويحاول المهندسون
معرفة كيفية نقله إلى الأرض في
حالة حدوث ذلك ،
يوضح كريس جيمس المساهم في CNN
سبب وجود اهتمام بالمشروع
مرحبًا كارل ، أنت تعلم أنني أحب اصطحابك يا رفاق
في مغامرات رائعة إلى بعض الأماكن
الأكثر
إثارة وغير المتوقعة في العالم ، واليوم
ليس استثناءً ،
سأخبركم عن
شيء لفت انتباهي حقًا
الفنادق العائمة هذه الظاهرة ظهرت
جميعًا  حول العالم في السنوات الأخيرة مع
دول الشرق الأوسط مثل
الإمارات العربية المتحدة وقطر تقود
الطريق بهياكلها المثيرة والمبتكرة ،
تحقق من هذا المفهوم الجديد من
فريق التصميم التركي الذي
يقود الطريق عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالوعي البيئي ،
يتميز هذا الفندق بـ 152 غرفة والحصول على
هذا لا يولد الكهرباء الخاصة به
فحسب ، بل يجمع أيضًا
ويعيد استخدام مياه الأمطار ومخلفات الطعام
، وقد عمل المصممون مع العديد من
الخبراء بما في ذلك
مهندسو بناء السفن  والمهندسين المعماريين
للتوصل إلى هذا المشروع الجريء
الذي كان قيد العمل منذ مارس
2020 ،
سيعمل هذا الهيكل العائم
بطريقة مماثلة للدينامو الذي
يستخدم تيارات المياه مع
توربينات الرياح وقوة المد والجزر أثناء تدويره
لتحويل الطاقة إلى كهرباء
حركته  سيتم التحكم فيه من خلال
وضع
ديناميكي لبرنامج كمبيوتر يستخدم للحفاظ على
موضع واتجاه السفن
بالإضافة إلى المراوح والدوافع الآن ،
وأنا أعلم الآن أن ما تفكر فيه
لن يصيبك بالدوار مع كل هذا
الدوران الجيد ، تطمئن
إلى أن المصممين يقولون إن الضيوف  من غير المحتمل أن
تعاني من
أي دوار حيث يستغرق الأمر 24 ساعة
حتى يدور الفندق
360 درجة كاملة على الرغم من ذلك  (ح) المشروع
ليس له سعر تقديري
لكن الفريق حدد تاريخ الانتهاء 2025